I thank you yes sir and I'm joined in
the studio by Emily Allred Emily you
serve as a curator in the World Chess
Hall of Fame and well I know that now
you have a very new exhibition which is
dedicated to tslr the American famous
poet who was raised in and born in Saint
Louis please tell us more about this
exhibition yeah so this exhibition just
opened a few weeks ago it was curated by
Francis Dickey who is an expert in T.S
Eliot scholar it explores Elliot's early
life here in St Louis the influence that
his family had in the city as well as
one of his most important contributions
to literature the Wasteland
well there is a very interesting fact
that Rick sinkerfield he is a huge
admirer of TS Elliot poetry but could
you tell us is there a link between TS
Eliot and chess
enjoyed the game and he played chess
correspondence chess with his father we
actually have a photo of his father
playing chess in the show
he also included a section in the
Wasteland titled a game of chess and
it's influenced by plays that integrated
the game into them and it also includes
a couple playing chess and so what are
the most interesting artifacts that the
visitors can see this exhibition yeah
Elliott was really well read and he
literature and philosophy into the
Wasteland and so people can listen to
the poem read by local actors but they
can also see these different books and
other Publications that he integrated
into his writing we have also some
really fun things like antique tarot
cards antique chess sets things that he
refers to in the poem
thank you and the last question because
the tournament has taken place in the
world Chess Hall of Fame so how does it
feel to see all these players they lead
well do you follow the games of course
and well the players themselves are
almost like the part of the exhibition
yeah we did a really wonderful tour for
some of the Players yesterday who are
competing in the championship and that
was really exciting just to see them
here and it you know as a historian it's
also cool to see history being made you
know live right here in St Louis thank
you very much and well please visit the
exhibition at the world chairs Hall of
Fame and well how many visitors did you
have so far oh we're so busy today you
know summer breaks you have families
coming from around the country all
wanting to see the Hall of Fame
hi and there is I think another
exhibition the song Moves which is uh
well taking place right now yeah there
that's on view on our first floor um
it's carried by our chief curator Shane
Bailey and her husband Bradley Bailey
and so there's a lot to see there there
are costumes from the Super Bowl
halftime show with Katy Perry
um there's also things related to chess
players who are also musicians there's
classical hip-hop country just a little
bit of something for everyone so now
that I asked about that so which is your
favorite piece in this exhibition uh so
in Elliott some of my favorite things I
really like we have bricks on view that
are on loan to us from the National
Building Arts Center which is a Museum
located right across the river from us
and Elliott's father was the president
of the hydraulic press Brick Company so
literally St Louis was kind of made his
family's built into the fabric of the
city so it's cool to see these they look
really humble but they're really
interesting artifacts six
so if you get a chance once you get and
once again please visit the vultures
Hall of Fame and right in front of your
screen you have the tallest chest piece
in the world yes yeah it's incredible to
walk past every day when you go into
work and see it's really sweet to see
people taking their pictures with it
every day yes you have an amazing
professional environment I might say yes
I envy you oh well we're happy to have
you here in St Louis and hopefully see
you more in the future too thank you so
much
thank you Emily and for everything you
in the World Chess Hall of Fame do